¿Cuáles son los factores Lo que voy también
en el ansa nuboso
Buenas noches
y seis series presenta afortunadamente
cadagno que en colombia este año sera
la condición de presentar Catania
uniforme que muestra los estados por encima de la
Consecuencias en la humanidad Exactamente malas
juntos
en realidad la estadística
statuestroes y de la autoridad Des
las colombianas pueden ser incluso peores
de la situacion como estas yo lo digo
continuado Como existe y ha sido
smithsomi 20 dors y manifiesta un
contacto incomodo eh victimas ed
expresamente masiva que
singuenti ociomil ehm un aumento en
casos de comparativa exportación 2021
desesperación individual 123 mi persona
él displased un asiento un
displasia sí individualmente en el muestreo
de diciembre
2015/77.000 es decir con aumento del mosto
en un 60%
en lo más mínimo registran que es
nada
de artefacto explosivo no se si es 1.7
el descanso del personal continúa la guerra
Artefacto delgado dijo que nace
descontrolado y si el número massalto es
de los últimos césagnos
porque sur occidente del la estaba jugando
país sí que siendo uno en su
violencia de guitarra
en realidad las sonas De Frontier con
Venezuela y el occidente del país es el sur
del país que en las masas frittatas son
los jonas de donde si de la luz
territorial
no sólo con la consecuencia directa
donde entra en el medio de la luz aparece
contra el territorio territorial el
contrasocial
afortunadamente atrapó a Desa como
consecuencia
buertes desaparessiones y expresamente
inconvenientes en ventiladores Dos Miller
registramos 3400
Recién aceptados, siempre se delatan
del territorio de Colombia que es
en rodajas para ejercicios
anteriormente la Región en materia estructural
si pues señor que si el hada de la oportunidad
la presencia obligada de las estatuas crea la
muy asqueroso
y es conflictarmadus de ella
Seguían despidiéndose Por supuesto que el
iniciativa del gobierno colombiano habla
de las tiendas conversan duramente con el
sarmatosis desarrollo jesperamos que sea
poeta con glievar es una reducción de
fritos de la población civil y en
mi interes seguiremos en stravando
del sector sarmatos yablando con iOS en
confidencialidad bilateral para
que respeta la directiva internacional
humanitario tras la guerra
parametrizar las consecuencias de la
derrotado para loschiano participar
incluso cardio en la delgada ahora
el proyecto de comida total del gobierno
Pedro puedes ser una escalada para
conflicto a veces
potencialmente sí y he oído hablar de eso
alguna iniciativa en la que soy malo
parar salir el salteado ligado a
conflictivo
excelente se trata de un proceso, por supuesto
que tampoco es facil por la pregunta
estructural porque estaba hablando
de antemano, sin embargo, nos despedimos si
la sniziativa que puede reducir de
grado de derrota i potencialmente
permitirá que las palomas asciendan ahora
derrotado eres despertado violencia como el quiere
digamos le vamos a dar la serca de la victima si
seguiremos que ay en negociacion
internacional
de la situación